every single episode of the Mindy
project says caution caution beware
know exactly to the point where now it's
like not even like now it's just like
this is a godless show what are you
doing with your life that you're
watching this show right it's there's um
and we try we're like okay guys let's
put to be classy for once in our lives
like let's not have an episode that
needs a warning at the beginning to tell
you to hide your children right and it
never works Conan wait so you actually
have had you start out trying to have a
good episode and then it just ends up
going to a dirty place when you start
writing it ultimately like my inner
pervert can't not to do these episodes
good the warnings are just like in front
of every what's an example of a show
you've done where it got much racier
than you thought it was going to get
initially there is it episode we did
this season that was it was called I
slipped and we we did it I feel like in
a way where we never really talked about
what it was about but it was about a
boyfriend taking certain liberties with
his girlfriend and like a kind of
heightened sexual my my love interest in
the show Danny tries to do something a
little different in bed mm-hmm and that
one was I couldn't believe that was like
I'm on Fox so what was the warning in
front of that one do not watch this yeah
I gotta see that episode yeah I feel
like I didn't sweat it was very
confusing to people that I didn't it was
about what it was about anal sex which I
think I can take TBS
I didn't want to say it and then I was
realizing that it was constant list
because no one knew what I was talking
about well we know what you're talking
about it happen it didn't happen it was
just alluded to yeah that was one of
those ones where I was like I think it
was just confusing enough so that
elderly people and young people wouldn't
be able to understand what was going on
and then I'll have a pervert in between
together so there's like a grandma right
now going oh it's about anal sex tried
it didn't like it it was what Eisenhower
was in office you can say it a lot on
this network on your cell you were I
don't think we say it
while most TBS sitcoms are about angels
yeah that's the whole genre of show yeah
yeah
there's whole blocks of programming
right that's just about anal sex we
don't say it that often no I don't come
out every night and go hey everybody
shut ur night anal sex
[Applause]
this crowd likes it well
they don't like us talking about it they
like like most people they like the idea
yeah have you really got it interesting
when they started talking about anal sex
yeah that tends to happen
that's right tend to steer every
interview
Vern's loved your baseball your
baseball documented no Shoeless Joe
Jackson any anal sex in his life there
goes my peabody again
you